la primer pregunta
qué me dice
y que les haga ustedes
qué es la pobreza
por allí algunos se imaginan que la
pobreza tiene que ver con esto
y la verdad que desde muy chico creía
que la pobreza o me dice 'no entender
que la pobreza tenía que ver con esto yo
soy el quinto de seis hermanos yo mi
mariela marcela mauricio yo y oscar lo
decimos en san juan y nos vinimos a
buenos aires a buscar el oro y el moro
mi padre le habían prometido trabajo
casa auto éxito esta es la única foto
que tengo de mis padres juntos porque
buenos aires a mi padre lo mata se
termina muriendo a los pocos años de
estar acá y ahí empezó una lucha eterna
por tratar de vivir con dignidad
con tratar de mejorar la calidad de vida
que nos tocó vivir
suponemos un terreno con mis hermanos
éramos pobres
personas que vivían
en un terreno usurpado
que no teníamos a veces ni siquiera para
cenar sin embargo a pesar de todo esto y
a pesar de haber vivido
la discriminación y señalarnos como
enseñaron durante muchos años a toda mi
familia
a mí había algo que siempre me enamoro y
siempre siempre me gustó
yo amo la música yo soy músico
y realmente descubrí la música a través
de una mujer que cuando la escuchaba
mira
para mí increíble yo la miraba a ella
era como un ángel
yo me sabía todas sus canciones todas
sus letras todas sus coreografías
me aprendí todas las melodías tenías
todos sus cassette en esa época había
cassette y realmente para mí era una
estrella era un ángel
esta mujer agredida o mato humana
genial va con la adicción a bélgica mi
mamá mamá quiero ser gladys mi médico a
hijo no te gusta antonio ríos no leo
alcides no no yo quería ser gratis mi
mamá me decía bueno pero la nueva luna
no no no yo soñaba con alguna vez sido
un artista como ella siempre soñé con
aprender a tocar sus temas entonces un
gran amigo mío de la infancia guardo que
su mamá trabajaba en el barrio olga
desarrollando proyectos para que
personas como yo que vivíamos en estos
barrios podríamos estudiar así en un
proyecto en una fundación que vale la
pena que trabajaba con el arte en
contexto de pobreza mi amigo me dijo un
día que danielle porque nos deje de
romper la bola con la música y te anotás
en el centro cultural comunitario donde
daban talleres gratuitos de teclado del
piano y yo dije no yo voy a trabajar
clase de piano ridículo yo tengo que
salir a hacer que nuestra vida tenga
sentido y él me decía pero nada
a la clase de piano y note en la clase
de piano
los sábados a las 9 de la mañana
y resulta que esta fundación había una
profesora concertista de piano llena
alpern
quedaba una vez por semana un par de
horas de clases gratis a las personas
que no podíamos pagar la clase
fui a la clase de piano cuando tenía
nueve años y labial y no profesora de
piano contactos un chal de seda anteojos
ojos verdes rubia yo la miré ella me
miró y me dijo cómo te llamas
danielle y qué haces acá había un piano
vertical al lado de ella y yo dije yo
quiero tocar eso mis así y qué queréis
tocar
y yo le dije
y oma tucumana de queso
y sea médico
y quién es esa mujer
como usted de profesora de música no sí
la verdad que sí pero
la verdad que no conozco a todos los
músicos pero si vos traes un café de
ella yo lo escucho y te enseño en serio
y yo sí
voy a mi casa hago regla 6 lo traigo y
lyle empezó
sí sí sí sí sí do re do re di mi fa sol
sido
dije guau
empezó a enseñar y yo me sentía creación
lento ganó y más teniendo náusea
usa
dice me dijo mi ángel
nos puedes aprender esto y mucho más si
vos que les enseño a profes si puedes
aprender todo lo que quieras aprender y
el otro sábado les lleve la nueva luna
los charros sí la aprendí a tocar había
una banda que se llamaba los palmeras
que yo soñaba
y me enseñó toda la música que yo quería
aprender
al poco tiempo yo ya había aprendido
todo lo que quería y me dijo y ahora qué
crees aprender y yo dije yo aprendí a
tocar lo que quería aprender y se mira
daniel con estos mismos acordes existe
un tipo que llama beethoven sabéis que
es de beethoven siles que son un perro y
una película
no es un perro beethoven es un músico
que toca para elisa y me mostró para
elisa cuando escuche para elisa me
enamoré de para elisa y yo dije si yo
puedo tocar eso que tiene me dijo un
poder tocar eso y mucho más también todo
lo que vos quieras tocar y ahí aprendí a
los 9 años a romper con la primer
pobreza que es la pobreza lo cultural yo
solamente pensé que la música
su pensé que la música es lo que
escuchaba en mi barrio pero no sabía que
existían otro tipo de música
y así aprendí a hacer no solamente
músico sino a los 14 años lily me vuelve
a poner un desafío con una compañera que
tocamos los dos pianos juntos marcela tú
la que todos sabíamos a clases bueno
ahora ustedes después de cinco años de
tomar clases gratis en el centro
cultural tienen que empezar a dar clases
a otros y es que no solo yo no puedo
alcanzar a otros y ustedes pueden dar
clases a otros y yo no tengo nada para
darme dice mirada para dar no hace falta
que tengas algo no bolsillo lo único que
tienes que hacer es querer ayudar a
otros entonces empecé a dar clases en mi
barrio con marcela aprendimos los dos a
dar clases entonces en el barrio damos
clases a jóvenes los más principiantes
del barrio entonces pasé a ser el pibe
que se contaba en la esquina a mandarse
cargadas a el profesor del barrio yo
pasaba por la vereda me dicen profe
profe
como cuatro veces por la verdad
si me decían como le daba profesor si lo
hace un caramelo yo agarraba como cinco
porque claro
la hija del almacenero era mi alumna y
ahí aprendí a derivar otra pobreza que
la pobreza la dignidad
qué es la pobreza que se pierde porque
uno prohibido en los contextos en los
que vivimos
piensa
que solamente la pobreza tiene que ver
con el hambre y el frío es vinos y vida
de noche pero no para pobres a poco
tiene que ver con lo económico sino
tiene que ver que en que hacés vos para
proyectar tu proyecto de vida que hacés
vos
para poder decir quién sos sin importar
el título ni el cargo que tengas una
empresa sino quién sos como persona y
eso yo aprendí a 14 años para empezar a
dar clases a otros en mi barrio a los 17
años
a los 17 años y empezar a coordinar el
centro cultural comunitario con
actividades con jóvenes de los barrios
donde ya no me importaba solamente
aprender y enseñar yo sino lo que
hacíamos este grupo de jóvenes era
formarnos y empezar a pensar sobre cómo
nuestra comunidad como nuestro barrio
podría hacer actividades para que puedan
mejorar la calidad de vida ya no
solamente los que estudiábamos sino de
nuestra comunidad hacíamos eventos en
los barrios hacíamos festejamos el día
de los niños buscamos la necesidad de
nuestros barrios y empezábamos a mejorar
de vuelta no solamente en nuestra vida
sino la vida de nuestros vecinos a los
25 años luego de esta fundación porque
sentí que en claro de la pena yo ya
había pasado desde alumno docente
coordinador director ejecutivo del
programa inclusive esta forma va hacia
jóvenes sin temas políticos y empecé a
entender que tenía que poder derribar
otra de las pobrezas entonces empecé a
trabajar con una organización civil que
se llama inicia y lo que hicimos en
inicia fue
trabajar en el penal
porque un joven del penal que era el
hijo de una amiga mía lo vamos a ver
porque estaba ahí preso cuando fui al
penal lo primero que vi fue esos dibujos
que ustedes ven atrás de los jóvenes que
eran todos es como una galería de arte
eran todos dibujos donde ellos habían
dibujado todo lo que ellos querían bueno
entonces lo media cristian junto con
olga y le dijimos que cristian que hacen
hagan el penal nada no pero como
cristian que que nada y los lunes nada y
el martes nada
el jueves nadie yo dije usted por como
un taller donde ustedes puedan pensar el
error que cometieron por el cual están
acá adentro y puedan pensar un proyecto
una vez que sean el de penal y cristian
comentó varias eso por mí claro que sí
entonces empezar un montañero donde
hablábamos del liderazgo de que ellos
puedan liderar su proyecto de vida
teníamos un libro que llaman nuevos
líderes que era de esta asociación civil
y los nuevos líderes tenían capítulos
como por ejemplo la transformación
personal el bien común la ética los
valores cada capítulo lo leíamos con los
presos con los 48 presos que fueron al
taller
no solamente eso sino que armamos un
cómic y cada uno podía poner el cómic lo
que se quedaba poner ese capítulo y ahí
rompió otra pobreza que la pobreza del
prejuicio es la que le sobró nuestra
compañera más temprano uno piensa que
las personas que están privadas de
libertad
no solamente se merecen estar ahí sino
también son personas que no tienen la
capacidad y la dignidad de poder cambiar
su futuro si pueden cambiar su futuro lo
único que necesitan son oportunidades y
yo ahí lo que estaba viendo es una
oportunidad
pero no solamente con esta pobreza de
ríver pobreza el prejuicio después me
tocó trabajar en otro proyecto donde un
compañero un chabón conocido un
gastronómico que tenía en el bajo de
salir de una cadena de restaurantes
disco chayanne y enfrente de mi
restaurante está la villa martín y omar
y la verdad no sé qué hacer porque cada
vez que paso por ahí me dicen bigote de
tener a europa a mí y me y si yo no sé
qué hacer entonces lo que hicimos un
programa se llama cocina para integrar
que lo que hacíamos este gastronómico
les enseñaba a las mujeres de la villa
martin llamar a que sean chef a que
puedan formarse ya no solamente como
personas que se dedican a las charlas
sino también un oficio como el
gastronómico y ahí rompió otro prejuicio
yo rompe otra pobreza que a la pobreza
de pensar que personas que viven en
contexto de vulnerabilidad solamente
puede trabajar de changarines no son
profesionales que también se pueden
formar en oficio como el oficio de ser
chef
en el camino me encontré con otra
persona que también me ayudó a romper a
otro de mi pobreza
esta persona nos conocimos una charla
juntos y él tenía una empresa donde
desarrollaba productos con diseño un
calzado con diseños distintos a su
charla a una empresa joven que exportaba
a distintos países de todo el mundo yo
vendí charla y él me dice tenés que
trabajar conmigo y yo dije tomás aunque
creo que elabora como hace la empresa
vos tenés que hacer en mi empresa lo que
vamos a hacer no barrio tiene que
trabajar en mi barrio que es mi empresa
con mi comunidad con mis empleados y te
creés cada creo que seas el gerente de
recursos humanos y que pero thomas jones
en limpiar sueldo bien no no me importa
eso lo vas a aprender lo que vos a veces
escuchar y estar con la gente
después de trabajar tres años con él me
propone ser además eso yo soy el gerente
de cultura y felicidad en el sector
privado
me dedico
ya no solamente médico voy a trabajar en
los barrios mejora la calidad de vida de
las personas en los barrios sino también
las empresas empiezan a pensar que todas
las personas que trabaja una empresa
pueden mejorar su calidad de vida y
tienen que trabajar siendo felices y
trabajar la cultura de esa empresa
me preguntaban hoy bueno y cuál es tu
riqueza
dice que ésta tiene que ver
con esto con haber formado una familia
con mi mujer con mis hermanos con mis
amigos
ser el padre de lautaro y catalina que
tiene dos meses de vida yo les quiero
decir algo cualquiera de los que está
acá cualquiera puede ser una liviana
albert cualquiera de ustedes le puede
dedicar una vez por semana a alguien
para que transforme su vida
miren chicos
a pesar de su pobreza económica o de su
riqueza económica no hagan de que sus
vidas sea una vida pobre muchas gracias